new zealand's is a remarkable country
with little more than four and a half
million inhabitants in a service area of
268 thousand square kilometers it is a
little bit smaller than Japan or Italy
it is located in the South Pacific and
we could say it New Zealand is far from
well literally everything because even
though it feels like it's right near
Australia by looking at the map these
two countries are separated by more than
1,600 kilometers at their closest this
is why we can find their endemic species
such as the Kiwi and non-flying
nocturnal bird despite being such an
isolated country New Zealand has managed
to become not following a rather unique
model one of the countries in the world
that enjoys one of the highest standards
of living in this first video we're
going to tell you about some of the most
striking keys to New Zealand success
[Applause]
[Music]
there is an austere peated comments or
feeling if you wish which takes place
over and over again every time someone
is asked about new zealand's after eight
visits they all say it as a country of
congeniality and quality of life a
country that everyone seems to want to
go back to I'm happy to say
categorically that I have found no other
country that aligned more with my view
of the future than New Zealand Peter
teal so if something is for sure it is
that New Zealand is above all a
welcoming integrating country so how
about we look at a piece of evidence for
that well do consider this one out of
four of New Zealand's inhabitants has
been abroad and here sign language is
considered an official language less it
isn't certain we have plenty of reasons
to be happy and more than satisfied
further New Zealand is one of the top
five safest countries in the world its
economy is the third freest on the
entire planet
and according to the doing business
ranking it is the number one country in
the world when it comes to the ease of
doing business
yep you heard that right New Zealand
dethrone Singapore as easiest place to
do business but this it's not the end of
our story today not even close
New Zealand is also considered the least
corrupt country in the world along with
Denmark employment rates here are higher
than the average in the OECD and it has
excellent educational sanitary and
cultural systems in other words New
Zealand is both an economic and social
success story but leaving all of that
aside in this video we're going to focus
on one of the most distinctive keys to
its success and that's the countryside
New Zealand a land of farmers
New Zealand is the only developed
country where the primary sector has
become more relevant in the last three
decades this sector represents today
almost seven percent of the country's
economy to highlight just quite how much
this is consider the fact that the
primary sector is just 1.6 percent of
the economy of the European Union four
times less than New Zealand even Spain
whose primary sector represents a little
more than 2% of its economy and is
considered the orchard of Europe looks
pretty ridiculous when compared to the
countries that we're discussing today
there is simply no equivalent in the
entire world
for example milk and dairy here are the
largest exports from New Zealand in fact
if we add both the primary sectors of
the agri-food industry these two
represent 60% of the nation's trade
exports
[Music]
[Applause]
did you have really thought this could
be possible that the countryside could
be the main economic engine in the
country with one of the best welfare
systems and standards of living on the
entire planet it is quite simply rather
amazing the agricultural competition
here is so high that they even managed
to achieve this without having to rely
on governmental subsidies consider the
difference yeah every year the European
Union grants agriculture and livestock
subsidies worth around twenty one
percent total production in Spain alone
the European Union has foreseen that
they will have to give 55 billion US
dollars in farming support between the
years 2014 and 2020 and I'd be thinking
that the American system is any
different all right so in North America
subsidies are a bit lower than they are
in the EU but they are still around 8%
of all agricultural production and well
that's a loss now new zealand downs
handsome government subsidies but they
are just 0.9% of production which is 23
times less than the european union and
almost 10 times less than the united
states not bad right besides if this
wasn't enough using them spending is
mostly bound for investments and
innovation
[Applause]
as you can see they save a great deal
this 12 it hasn't always been the case
[Music]
Audra Nam --ax and the New Zealand their
farming revolution
in the early 1980s almost 40% of farming
income came from government subsidies at
the time the national economy was the
archetype of protectionism and the
system whelming didn't exactly work the
economy over the country was going
through a tough crisis the public
deficit was enormous almost 10% of the
national GDP there was double digit
inflation the external debt and
unemployment kept rising and the economy
was in a state of stagnation now in 1984
the economics minister of the recently
elected Labour government rancher
Douglas started an ambitious reform
program known as Raja na mcc's
in this program in many areas of the
economy were liberalized and this
included the primary sector and these
changes they took place almost overnight
price controls were eliminated and most
farming subsidies were removed
furthermore in order to fight inflation
the government decided to raise interest
rates this was really unpopular and
farmers were angry since they had gone
into debt in previous years it was the
perfect storm in some holes debt
interest spending increases and there
was a fall in the price of lands as you
can imagine this change wasn't easy and
it all seemed to indicate a future
disaster however the country soon felt
the benefits of putting an end to
subsidization the income fool encouraged
farmers to looks at innovations capable
of raising the levels of production they
introduced new crops improve the quality
of their current crops and used more
ecological farming methods they simply
have to find a way to stand out from the
crowd on the other hand they began to be
very careful about cost and this it
wasn't just about maximizing the
production of subsidized products they
had to improve the value chain adapt to
consumers and reduce costs let's
consider an example subsidizing
fertilisers had resulted in the careless
use of them when there were no more
subsidies for these fertilisers the use
of fertilisers fell without affecting
production farmers learned to only use
them whenever necessary which helped
with the cost of production that also
helps the environment the same happens
with other things and this created a
more efficient and sustainable
agricultural system when we consider the
new crops and products that new zealand
started producing there is probably no
better example than that of the wine
industry
the safes dedicated to Vineyards has
almost tripled in the last decade and
New Zealand wine has become known around
the world
moreover with the goal of finding new
revenue sources the rural population
started to develop additional businesses
like rural tourism or elaborate
agri-food products like closely relying
on environmental preservation and highly
valued brands
[Music]
this meant that farmers started to
commit to the protection of the
environment
now farmers realized that preservation
of the ecosystem was also profitable in
economic terms the result of this well
it was an incredible revolution in the
end only 800 interests 1% of all of them
had to close down and in the next 20
years after 1986 the production in this
sector grew by 40% and pay close
attention to that figure since the
removal of subsidies the primary sector
has grown more than the rest of the
economy between 1986 and 2006 the
primary sector had sustained growth of
5.9 percent per year
[Music]
so New Zealand really has thrived after
the removal of subsidies along with this
progress internalization was also key it
led the New Zealand countryside
competitively exports more than 90
percent of its production and in
addition to all of that it's all
incredibly environmentally friendly so I
think what else could we possibly ask
for New Zealand dear viewer it's the
perfect example of how bad policies and
subsidization can damage innovation
diversification and productivity while
at the same time creating a burden for
the public economy this is exactly what
is happening with the capt european
protectionist agricultural policy which
costs around fifty billion euros every
single year on the contrary
new zealand shows that by doing things
right it is not only possible to save a
lot of money but at the same time it's
possible for rural areas to improve
substantially new zealand has absolutely
proven that farming can prosper without
public aid and while new zealand is
trying to double their farming exports
by 2025 the rest of the countries are
still involved in the debate around
subsidization but that's our opinion
here at fish apology and we'd now love
to know what you think do you think the
countryside will die without public aid
could New Zealand's success could be
replicated somewhere else well we'd love
to know what you think please let us
know in the comments below and if you
enjoyed our video please do hit that
like button and also subscribe for brand
new videos twice a week also do check
out our friends of the we consider media
podcasts they provided the vocals in
this episode but we're not mine and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]